Let's do this together.
so
this is for
example one
this is pmf.
and CDF exercise
one
Okay.
And how many questions do we have three?
This is question one.
Is exercise one by the way?
You have two three questions question one question two.
and question three
so
here's how we figure out.
that P4
What is the probability?
for
the fourth or the value 4 in the random variable well
It calculate this.
You're asking.
Here's however, do it first of all add up.
the first
four probabilities so you would say
P0
zoom in a little bit so you can see more clearly.
So we have and then one.
and then two
and then three
and then four
Oh without four.
Let's do these first three if the add up.
You get 0.9.
If you add these up numbers, so this point 30
plus 0.25. That's 55.
And then 75 and the plus Point 15, it's
90.
So the first four add up to
point 90
if they all add up to point 90
and we know for a fact that the probability stops at
one.
What could the probability of four possibly be?
I mean the first four have taken up.
0.90 of the probability number
what is left?
The answer is point 10.
right
Add these two numbers together and you get one.
this
exercise is to stress that probability cannot go past
one.
question number two
What is the probability that at least two patients visit the clinic during office
hours?
So the answer is the probability for two is point
two and then point three.
And then point four we already found that right point four. We know it's it's
point 10.
So Point 20 plus 0.50 plus point 10.
so
Point 20 or let me write it down this way you have to probably have
two plus the probability of three plus the probability
of 4.
For probability of two we have Point 20.
For probably a three what was it 15?
and for four we had
point 10
Okay. So question you want to give us the probability for?
when four patients show up to the clinic
that was point 10.
And then we use that to our advantage.
because the first
for for two patients and three patients that probably was
given we take the one from for four patients add them
all together and we get the answer which is four point.
0.45
What is the third question?
What is the problem this is very similar. What is a probability that more
than two patients visit the clinic during office hours.
More than two patients same like let
me give you this the same.
Like you're looking at the answer more than two patients.
more than two patients
I'll leave this out here.
so you can
more easily solve the problem.
I'll give you more. I'll give you more hint.
so here
The question is asking. What is it probability?
That more than two patients.
So that's X.
Well more than two patients. That's three or greater.
right
In other words, what is the probability that X will take on
3?
or
or X will take on 4.
We can't go past four. I mean that's that's that's the maximum
number of patients that are allowed inside the clinic.
I encourage even those who are not answering questions to at least think about
it.
Matthew Anders, David who wants to answer this question
Should I continue the answer? I'm going to go ahead and type in top at the
answer.
Yeah, but don't put your share and don't share your answer
in the channel for everyone to see.
but yeah, that's the
that's the correct answer.
Okay.
So the answer is you know.
You just have to accumulate add
up the numbers out of the probability.
For when you have three patients or patients?
So essentially we have P of
3.
Plus
then adds up to 0.25.
if you take
A 0.3. Excuse me the probability for
X at 3 it's 0.15.
And probably of X being at
and probably have X at 4. Well, we already talked about it's point
point one. So point three plus.
point 10 that gives us Point 25